so my name is David Gerson and today I'm
going to be presenting a quick workflow
that I developed to kind of help me
understand kind of media brand
positioning specifically the goal of
this analysis is to create a perceptual
map and and what is a perceptual map or
perceptual map is one of these really
classic matrices that are always
developed by consultants and other sorts
of people to take a lot of complex
information condense it literally into
four boxes maybe less and then display
that to people so they understand
exactly what's going on either in their
industry or simply just going on with
their own product mix so the example
that I'm showing here is very similar to
what we'll be working on and what it has
is it's just showing you know you have
your dog's cash cows rising stars of
potentials and what these are is they're
different you know different product
types and the performance of them in the
potential future growth and so that's
the two axes that are available so the x
axis is the revenue that's being
produced by these different products and
the success / growth is the potential
they have to keep growing another famous
example of this is the gartner's magic
quadrant which is used frequently for
almost everything in IT and if you're at
you know the IT conference there's a
chance you've probably seen one before
the issue is there's a small problem
with how these are developed the biggest
problems are that for the most part it's
very qualitative and when they're not
qualitative typically that means
somebody has a scorecard and they're
going through and they're checking off
each box on this scorecard and that's
helping them to determine really where
somebody is on the x-axis and where they
are on the y-axis and then they're
simply plotting them but they're still
using a qualitative measure to determine
what's going into that scorecard and for
the most part it's not even happening
with that level of degree it's simply
somebody looking at a chart defining
what their measures are going to be and
then plotting them as they see fit in
trying to do this themselves and as you
know data scientists and very
quantitative people that's not the
approach and it doesn't make the most
sense perceptual mapping is a way that
this is done specifically in marketing
so that what you can do is you can
assess where your products are at and
see what they're doing additional
features that you can add to it are kind
of adding in the difference not only
products but your product features so
what this is that this is a perceptual
map of the soft drink industry and it's
showing that not only do you have
lemonade coke fanta etc but then you can
also add in the different components
that make you know a soft drink a soft
drink or make another product popular
and then from here you can determine
where there's room to move in the market
if let's say you think that there needs
to be a popular drink that's natural and
high-end taste but let's say maybe you
wanted to remove the sugar and then you
would decide position your product away
from sugar but still try to keep other
features that are very similar to
products in that quadrant and this is
just another example of how this can be
used effectively in this case with
cereal so we see that we really don't
have anything that has good taste and
high nutrition instead we have a lot of
things that taste just okay or are
covered in sugar and that's the state of
cereal and what we want to do is we
would look at this and say oh they're
obviously needs to be something in that
corner so for this process I developed I
initially designed a workflow like this
at PI data Dallas where I started
learning python getting involved in the
community and figuring out exactly how
Python can help me typically the work I
do is in our so I don't know much about
Python but a lot of those same skills
apply universally as long as I know the
different components that I need to
perform an analysis the advantage of
Python though is that when i'm using
python and able to not only use the
different data analysis and data
manipulate manipulation techniques but
also if i need to integrate with a web
service AKA the twitter web service I
have a very easy way to do that starting
with my Twitter integration
it was incredibly easy at least to start
with Twitter recently changed their API
while I was in the middle of this
project and then threw a wrench in the
gears to say the least but you can still
go through and use the Twitter streaming
application to monitor a few key either
hash tags or keywords that you would
like to be looking for the tool that I
used was twice on and what made that
great is as you could see in this line
right here all of I'm not sure can you
see my screen there right here at the
very bottom that's the one line that
actually starts my streaming API that's
all I need everything else is just me
telling it you know what are you going
to be streaming and then I'm also
telling it you know here's my
authentication tokens for the web
service so the data I pulled I basically
set up this web service and I kept it
running on an additional computer I had
set up in my home for about a week so I
had a week's full of tweets based on
what was in Twitter for the different
companies that you can see so Burger
King McDonald's Pizza Hut Taco Bell
chipotle qdoba etc now there were some
limitations with this though as I said
while I was in the process of doing this
the fire hose API was shut down and also
when I was using the [ __ ] thon package I
noticed that I wasn't able to filter on
language so the initial goal of this was
I was going to have two pieces of data
the first was going to be the
information I have about the different
brands I'm looking at so my McDonald's
Pizza Hut different food companies that
I would be analyzing and creating a
perceptual map for the other part of
this is I would need to figure out which
terms were important when I'm looking at
these types of companies that don't
necessarily apply to the entire span of
Twitter just because if you've ever been
on Twitter people don't talk like they
normally do on Twitter people are very
crazy on Twitter and what makes that
challenging is when you're trying to
just find normal words and see how they
apply in a regular context that doesn't
necessarily work within
you know the context of a tweet so what
i did is i had to find an additional
data set that wasn't necessarily on
twitter and it all had to be in english
fortunately however swiftkey which is
currently using their data for I think
they do some sort of automatic keyboard
that's available for Android they
provide a data set where they have a
bunch of different tweets that people
have been using in the US so that you
can try to predict what people will be
using when they're using the swiftkey
keyboard so I use that rather than fire
hose data because was more readily
available and the fire hose API was shut
down the next step was tokenization it's
actually incredibly simple because if
you're loading your data in as a string
you just press you know dot split and
then I do the you know dot split for a
new line and then i create a new
function that's just going to simply do
a lambda and then for each line i'm also
going to split by string and that's
tokenization there's tokenization
available in a variety of other packages
but that was the way I did it in this
case also while i was doing tokenization
i decided to filter based on words or
tokens that i knew i wouldn't be
bringing forward so this would be things
like you know very small words that
would appear to commonly in just a lot
of stop words that are very well-known
so I didn't need to use processing power
later on down the road to get rid of
them also ID duped my data because I
noticed there was a lot of spammers who
would continually say the exact same
thing to the company's I was trying to
monitor and it didn't make sense to have
you know their voices heard heard a lot
especially if they were boat's just kind
of repeating the same thing over and
over again the next step in the analysis
was stemming so stemming is extremely
cool because when you have a word that
you're analyzing you have both the roots
and then you have kind of whatever's
left so if I'm saying you know I moved
here that's basically me just saying
move and then I have an additional
suffix on that but really I'm looking
for the word move
that's the most important and if I'm
looking at kind of the general view of a
company taste and tasted are very
similar so the algorithm I used
specifically was something called the
porter algorithm that part I think you
can bring it in as part of NLT k but in
this case I was just using I think it
was the porter package because once i
had that available i simply just told it
you know stem all of these words and it
would do that you know the newer version
of the algorithm is porter to and in the
context of this analysis it worked
really well it did take a while but i
think it was worth it because all of my
words you know could be tied together
regardless of know whether they were
being used as a verb or an adjective or
a noun as far as the algorithm goes i'm
not going to dive into it but i did find
a very good document which is posted at
the bottom it's just a lecture on the
different steps this algorithm goes
through when it's trying to stem a word
from that first that list of stemmed
fast food restaurants and the stem
firehose data I brought that into a
tf-idf analysis the reason I did this is
because I wanted to see which terms in
that food data set we're more important
than the terms in the firehose data set
and once again that was incredibly easy
and I'll show you just how many lines of
code that took using the psych hit learn
package the reason that you needed to do
this is basically it just gives you a
score saying how important a word is so
right here what i did is i just created
a simple function that's able to take in
the raw string document and then using
the tf-idf pack tf-idf function from
scikit-learn you can also include a
tokenizer so in this case my tokenizer
is just saying split on word and it's
going to tokenize it again but that's
just the way the API works is that I
wouldn't feed in my tokenized data again
however since I had already stem to the
data and saved it off that really didn't
matter much and then I also decided I
would use the English
stop words so it would know to avoid any
stop words that are in the tf-idf
vectorize er package but not in the
initial stop words I used which was
through NLT k once I did that I would
then fit a transform which would tell me
how important the words are within my
base documents so that's the firehose
data and then I would return a transform
of the values to tell me how important
my words are from that compare docs data
which is the actual fast food
information that i was looking at after
that I just basically did a word count
the word count i used took a standard
dictionary and then it would plot it so
i had a dictionary object that would
hold the word count dictionary for each
of these different fast food terms
nothing really complicated they're the
only part that was even a little bit
tricky was just an intersection of you
know where my fast food terms would show
up and then making sure that I would
also add that word count and increment
them for each of those different
restaurants once again that's not super
complicated here we go finally we
actually dive into the part where I
create the perception ille perceptual
map so the perceptual map is basically
just kind of a dissimilarity matrix
that's then used to provide context when
your reap la ting your data onto a graph
so there are two main types of you know
dissimilarity matrices use the first one
is for your non-metric MBS so the
non-metric MDS is similar to pca and
that you're looking for continuous
variables when you're using the metric
MDS and you're trying to plot it for the
continuous variables it's not easy to
perform anything like a rank function
and for some other types of data it's
not always the best solution the answer
when you have something like a rank or a
comparison is the non-metric MDS which
is instead going to plot how a single
term or a single value compares to
another value for an element if you want
to think about this most easily
you're going to want to be looking at
uni dimensional data so in this case we
actually have the unit dimensional terms
for club hearts spades and diamonds and
this is seeing how easily people can
visualize this information and kind of
maintain the terms that they've seen
based on the difference I think the suit
of the card and so what you're then
doing is you're seeing how easily these
can be recognized versus how easily
other suits can be recognized and then
what you do is you compare the
differences between the by creating and
dissimilarity matrix once that's done
you then in this case what they did is
they performed a certain type of
optimization that required the values to
be above one so they multiply their data
by 1000 and then they reordered the data
so that everything was in the proper
order after that they simply just took
the sum of the left in the sum of the
right side and using that they were able
to order them on a single axis and what
we're doing is essentially this but on a
multiple axis chart so once we actually
get out of that there were a few
different ways that you could run MDS so
the first attempt i did was using
scikit-learn and this is what we got out
of it the only problem is it doesn't
maintain a lot of the information we
need to provide any context so obviously
we can see things that look like they
kind of make sense ki toba and
McDonald's are very close because
they're both great restaurants with high
brand support Burger King and Wendy's
are close Chipotle and Pizza Hut are
kind of close but we really don't know
why anything is in the place it's in
because I couldn't really get that to
work I decided to go back to our because
when I I'm very familiar with the
plotting libraries in our and I know
that they provide the exact information
that I need for this analysis so in this
case we're performing a standard metric
MDS solution to find out where these
different brands are positioned and what
we see here is that
all of these different brands are
plotted unfortunately though if you see
where the words are that actually tell
you which brand is located in a certain
location unfortunately it's not right
next to the dot that indicates it so if
you're looking at qdoba or pizza hut it
might be that that little blue dot at
the very bottom but there's no way to be
sure unless you go back and pull out the
raw data and try to map that yourself so
I decided this wasn't necessarily the
best fit just because it's almost
impossible to see what's going on here
the other solution was a non-metric
solution which I actually think worked
out very well so what this is plotting
is rather than trying to plot a dot and
then a text indicator for what that dot
means next to it you're just plotting
the text item itself and then the
different words for the terms that its
most closely related to and I'm going to
go into a little bit later what sort of
insights we can derive from this chart
specifically but it's very clear that we
can see what's going on and there's a
lot of good information here once we
start diving into it then the other
solution is like I said MDS is similar
to a PCA analysis so what you can do is
you can simply just create a PCA by plot
and that's going to plot your data a
little differently specifically using
the continuous elements of your data to
show the strength of certain
relationships or certain features and
map applied while this is useful one of
the main drawbacks of this specific type
of analysis is the goal isn't to provide
us with a concise view of the data so
what we end up having is we have a chart
that shows everything plotted on two
accesses but it's not giving us
necessarily the dissimilarity between
everything and unfortunately because
it's mostly trying to do a factor
analysis of the data it's not letting
you have more data elements than factors
so since we're only looking at eight
different companies we are limited to
only seven factors to analyze them and
we lose a lot of the information that we
would need by having so many terms from
Twitter so after going through all those
different packages the one that was
easiest to analyze was the non-metric
MDS solution from this what we can see
is that both Wendy's and Burger King
have favorable offering offerings of
both chicken and bacon taco bell doesn't
have any noticeable salad offering but
also McDonald's doesn't either which is
surprising because they've been you know
hyping up their salads for a long time
also price is frequently referenced when
people are talking about chipotle Pizza
Hut and McDonald's so they might want to
look into diving into those tweets and
seeing you know is it because the price
is to hire are people talking about
price a lot because the price is too low
also Taco Bell owns the term crunch if
you look at crunch it's very far in the
bottom and similar to where taco bell is
located what this would indicate is that
really nobody else has a crunchy
offering in taco bell kind of
exclusively owns that term so what we
would do next is first we would try to
find the profitability of these
different firms and plot that similar to
how the PCA was plotted on that previous
chart to show us really which of these
terms are the most profitable then
rather than looking at the firms and
seeing how far they they are away from
that one profitable line we would
actually be looking at the data elements
we're pulling from Twitter to see what
types of offerings could provide us the
most profit so in this case like I was
saying with crunch if we found that Taco
Bell was doing incredibly well had high
profit margins and was generating a lot
of revenue people might want to be
interested in looking into a crunchy
option for themselves finally as far as
pain points learned goes ascii and
unicode conversions are always a huge
pain so i had to go through all of my
different modules and basically make
sure that they knew i was looking for
unicode data rather than certain types
of ascii every once in a while I would
forget but after you know I ran into
this issue a few times I just became
very over-aggressive with making sure
everything was unicode
and even if it didn't look like it had
maybe accidentally been cast to ascii i
would still reconvert it myself just to
make sure that you know I never ran into
that problem later also since I was
developing this solution iteratively and
I'm just running it on a laptop and
there's a lot of data on Twitter
whenever I would run a certain
computationally difficult step I would
then save it off using pickle so I could
pick it right back up immediately rather
than text I mean that way I just needed
to read in the file and I already have
my data object back the exact way I was
using it initially while I initially did
this project as a way to test our
against Python while playing with the
plotting library I realized it's really
not worth the effort to fiddle with
something to do a function that already
works well in another language so the
output of this was simply an eight by
369 term matrice matrix which is more
than enough for any programming language
when I have data of that scope the
limitations of our when it comes to you
know parallel processing or processing
out of memory they really don't appear
also since I know I'm only going to be
doing plotting it made a lot of sense to
just do the plotting within our finally
I'm sure everybody else knows this if
they've been using Python for a while
scikit-learn has almost everything you
need they have a el día analysis which
is what I'm going to recommend I would
do next to reduce my dimensionality even
further and also everything in that
package runs extremely quickly and I
don't have any of the problems I have
using some of the more open source
packages that are available in the
community a lot of times I had a great
idea and I'd find a package that would
perfectly do it but the second I would
install it something would break there
were a lot of weird concerns or it was
almost too hard to implement and I had
none of those problems using
scikit-learn finally what I would start
doing next is I'd look into a latent
dirichlet analysis what that would do is
it would then topic model my tweets for
me so rather than looking at individual
words I would see the context on the top
that people are tweeting about and then
use that as my features for the MDS
analysis and hopefully that would allow
me to use either PCA directly or another
metric MDS solution all right are there
any questions oh I didn't so I was just
looking at the words themselves rather
than you know the context of them so I
guess a good example is I it was much
easier to look at chicken than to look
for people saying they were happy and if
you look closely at McDonald's they have
the two terms that are most closely
associated with each other our love and
hate and they're both right next to
mcdonalds so either people just feel
strongly about McDonald's one way or
another but there's no determination as
to which one is which oh there are other
questions I'll close out thank you for
your time today